r interne et plus la fusion avec air
france voulue par christian blanc est
officiellement entérinée aujourd'hui par
les assemblées générales philippe
visseyrias et fille libre
c'est sa première apparition publique
depuis une semaine et y en blanc l'homme
qui a dit non au gouvernement s'apprête
à quitter air france il campe sur ses
positions convaincu que son projet était
le bon par moment où nous avons
réussi à engager fortement dans l'avenir
du transport aérien français maintenant
pour le reste
il appartiendra à mon successeur et
nouvelle équipe de
progresser et de faire ce que
je me prépare au tour de christian blanc
une trentaine de représentants de l'état
et d'entreprises publiques actionnaires
de l'excellent terre il était là ce
matin pour entériner la fusion avec air
france aujourd'hui après 37 ans
d'existence air inter la principale
compagnie intérieure d'europe cesse
juridiquement d'exister ces onze mille
salariés font désormais partie du groupe
air france une intégration effective
depuis quelques mois qui n'a pas été
sans heurts avec des grèves à répétition
contre les décisions de christian blanc
depuis trois quatre ans avec l'arrivée
de christian blanc a été plutôt le
démantèlement de la compagnie air inter
plutôt que le développement donc c'est
vrai que l'on est un peu en deuil
aujourd'hui de notre compagnie il y aura
des filialisations d'activité puis ce
qu'on appelle le timeshifting c'est à
dire des licenciements massifs
enfin seuls nous sommes entrés dans un
cycle classique et c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi monsieur blanc était partisan
de la privatisation cet après midi aura
également lieu l'assemblée générale des
actionnaires d'air france christian
blanc voulait être l'homme de la fusion
et de la privatisation il n'a réalisé
que la première partie de son projet